[Musique]
tu me fais tourner la tête
mon manège à moi
c'est ouais
je suis toujours à la fête
et
quand je te prends dans mes bras
je ferai le tour du monde
ça ne tournerait pas à bruxelles
la terre n'est pas assez
mais tout dire autant toi
ah
oui parlons de la terre
pour qui elle se prend la terre
à
parier qu'elle sur terreur
jaeckel pour faire ton mystère mais pour
nous y'a pas de problème
car c'est pour la vie quand c'est mal
abc avait pas de lui même
nous on s'émeut
quand même
comme on est bien tous les deux
quand on est ensemble nos deux
key
oui on a tous les deux on
quand on s'aime comme nous deux je ferai
le tour du monde
ça ne tournerait pas plus que ça
[Musique]
j'ai beau chercher rats
là
mon manège à moi chez toi
[Musique]
on peut même changer de planète
tant que j'entends tankers qui va
[Musique]
j'entends des flonflons on doit fêter
mon manège à moi
chez toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle
[Musique]